the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so so in the second lecture we're
going to talk about through some design
patterns for parallel programming and
tell you a little bit but what a design
pattern is and why is it useful and some
of you if you've taken object-oriented
programming you probably already have
seen design patterns before so we ended
the last lecture with ok I understand
some of the performance implications how
do I go about paralyzing my program and
so this is why I found quite often in
books and talks on parallel programming
that essentially lays out four common
steps for for paralyzing your program so
often you start out with sequential
programs this shouldn't be surprising
since you know for a long time as you've
heard in earlier lectures people just
coded sequential code and that was just
good enough so now the problem is you
want to take that sequential code or you
want to still write sequential code just
because it's conceptually easier and you
want to be able to paralyze it so you
can map it down to you know your
parallel architecture which in this
example has 4 4 processors so the first
step is you take your sequential program
and you divide it up into tasks so
during the project reviews for example
yesterday when I talked to each team
individually you know we sort of talked
about this and you sort of stumbled on
you know these four steps whether you
realize it or not and so you come up
with these tests and then these are each
one essentially encapsulates some
computation and then you group them
together so this is some granularity
adjustment and you map them down to
processes so these are things you can
pose it to threads for example and then
you have to essentially plot these down
on to actual processors and they have to
talk with each other so you have to
orchestrate the communication and then
finally do the execution so step through
you know each one of these and at a time
so the decomposition and so recall that
you know this really affects or it's
just really is affected by Amador's law
and that if there's not a whole lot of
parallelism in the application your
decomposition is a waste of time
there's not really a whole lot to get
but what you're trying to do is identify
concurrency in your application and
figure out it what level to exploit it
so what you're trying to do is divide up
your computation into tasks and
eventually these are going to be
distributed among processors and you
want to find enough of them so you can
keep all the processors busy and
remember that you know the more of these
that you have this gives you a sort of
an upper bound on your potential
speed-up and as in the ray tracing
example that I showed the number of
tests that you have may vary at runtime
so sometimes you might have a lot of
raids bouncing off a lot of things and
sometimes you might not have a whole lot
of reflection going on so you know the
number of rays will change over time and
in other applications interactions for
example between molecules might change
in the molecular dynamics earlier the
assignment really affects granularity
this is where you've partitioned your
task you're trying to group them
together so that you're so that you're
taking an account what is the
communication cost going to be
what kind of locality am I going to deal
with and what kind of synchronization
mechanisms do I need and how often do I
need to synchronize so you specify your
your just your granular you such that
you end up with things that are load
balanced and you try to reduce
communication as much as possible you
know structure approaches might work
well you might look at the code do some
inspection you might understand the
application but there are some
well-known design patterns which is
essentially the thing I'm going to get
to to try to help you with this and nice
programmers really I think we worry
about partitioning first and so and this
is really independent of an architecture
or programming model just taking my
application and figuring out well what
are different parts that I need to
compose together to build my application
so I'm going to show you an example of
that and one thing to keep in the back
of your mind is that
the complexity of how much partitioning
work you actually have to do really
affects your decision so if you start
out with some piece of code or you wrote
your code in one way and you realize
that they actually paralyze it requires
so much more work and some user studies
we've done on sort of trying to get
performance from code it really affects
how much work you actually do and if
something requires a lot of work you
might not do it even though it might
have really high payoff so you want to
be able to keep complexity down so it it
pays off to really think well about your
algorithm and how you structure it ahead
of time and finally the last two stages
I've lump together it's really
orchestration mapping I have my tasks
they need to communicate so what kind of
computation primitives do I need what
kind of communication primitives doing
you - am i packaging things up into
threads and they're talking together
over or dmas or with shared memories and
what you want to do is try to preserve
locality and then figure out how to come
up with a scheduling order that says it
preserves overall dependence of the
computation so patterns really are
parallel programming by patterns is
meant to essentially give you a cookbook
or a set of recipes you can follow to
help you with the different steps
decompose a sign orchestrated map this
could lead to really high quality
solutions in some domains so in
scientific computations it's really you
know there's a lot of problems that are
well understood and well studied and
some of the frequently occurring things
have been abstracted out and sort of
recorded in patterns and there's another
purpose to pattern assuming that they
provide you with the vocabulary for you
know two programmers can talk to each
other and users right terminology and
that conveys a whole lot of information
right without having to actually go
through and you know understand all the
details you instance it instantly
instantaneously know you know if I use a
particular model it can also help with
software reusability I malleability
modularity all of those things that are
software engineering perspective from an
engineering perspective are important
so brief history you know it's uh I
found this in some of the talks I was
researching and it was a book by
Christopher Alexander from from Berkeley
in 1977 that actually looked at
classifying patterns or really listing
patterns from an architectural
perspective to try to look at what are
some patterns occur and living designs
and building and recording those so as
an example for example there's this
six-foot balcony pattern so if you're
going to build a balcony you should
build it six foot deep and you know you
should have it slightly recessed and so
on because this is what's commonly used
and these are the kinds of balconies
that are that have good properties
architectural II now I don't know
whether this book actually had a whole
lot of impact on how people design
architectures certainly not probably for
the Stata Center but some some patterns
from object-oriented programming I think
many of you have already seen these you
know by the Gang of Four in 1990 1995
really sort of organized and classified
and came up with different ways of or
captured different ways of programming
that people have been using you know
things like the visitor pattern for
example some of you might might know and
I think so in 2005 and not too long ago
there was a new book which I'm using for
to create some of these slides it really
came up with or recorded parallel
programming patterns for parallel
programming and they identified really
for design spaces I think these are sort
of structured to express or capture
different elements so some elements are
for the algorithm is expression so I've
listed those here and some are for
actual software construction or the
actual implementation so under algorithm
expression it's really the thing of
decomposition finding concurrency where
are my tasks and the algorithm structure
well you might need some some way of
packaging those tasks together too so
that they can talk to each other and be
able to
use a parallel architecture on the
software construction side you're
dealing slightly more low-level details
so what are some things you might need
at a slightly lower level of
implementation to actually get all the
computation that's expressed at the
algorithm level to work in run well so
I'm going to essentially talk about the
latter part in the next lecture and I'll
cover much of the algorithm expression
stuff here at least affine you
concurrency part in this talk and if
there's time I'll do algorithm structure
otherwise just talk about it next time
so let's say you're working with MPEG
decoding this is a pipeline picture of
an mpeg-2 decoder or rather block level
diagram of mpeg-2 decoder and you have
this algorithm and you're say okay and
what's paralyze this where's my
parallelism where's my concurrency so
you know in mpeg-2 you have some bit
stream you do some decoding on it and
you end up with two things you end up
with motion vectors that tell you you
know here's somebody's head in the next
scene it's moved to this particular
location and you also so these are
captured by the motion vectors and you
also do some space so this captures or
recovers temporal information and here
you recover spatial information so in
somebody's head you might have
discovered some redundancy so that
redundancy is eliminated out so you need
to now essentially decompress or undo
that compression so you go through some
stages you combine the two together
combine the motion estimation and now to
recover pictures to reconstruct the
image and then you might do some
additional stages this particular stage
here is indicated to be data parallel in
that I can do different scenes for
example in parallel or I might be able
to do different slices of the picture in
parallel so I can essentially take
advantage of data parallelism you know
the concept of taking a loop and
breaking it up as I should in lecture
five so in pass decomposition what we're
looking for is really independent
coarse-grained computation and these
often are inherent to the algorithm
so here I've outlined these in yellow
here you know so this is one particular
task I can
one thread of execution doing all the
spatial decomposition I can have another
thread decoding all my motion vectors
and in general you know that you're
looking for sequences of statements that
operate together as a group these could
be loops or they could be functions and
usually you want these to essentially
just fall out of your algorithm as it's
expressed in a lot of cases it does so
depending on how you think about the
program you might be able to find he's
quicker or easier data decomposition
which I've highlighted here essentially
says you have same computation apply to
lots of small data element that you know
you can take your large hit element
partition into smaller chunks and do the
computation over and over and parallel
and so that allows you to essentially
get that kind of data parallelism
expansion in space and finally I'm gonna
make a case for pipeline parallelism
which essentially says well I can
recognize that I have a lot of stages in
my computation and it does help to
actually have this kind of decomposition
just because you know you're familiar
with pipelining concepts from other from
other domains so this this type of
producer to producer consumer chain is
actually beneficial so it does help to
sort of expose these kinds of
relationships so what are some
guidelines for actually coming up with
your task decomposition you know where
do you start
you have your algorithm you know you
understand the problem really well
you're writing some code and the hope is
that in fact that as I pointed out it
does happen that you can look for sort
of natural code regions that encapsulate
your computation so function calls
distinct loop iterations are pretty good
places to start looking and it's easier
you know as a general rule it's easier
to start with as many tasks as possible
and then fuse them to make them more
coarse-grained then to go the other way
around you know it impacts your software
software engineering decisions it
impacts you know software implementation
and impacts how you encapsulate things
and low-level details of implementation
so it's always easier to fuse than to
fit and you want to consider three
things you want to keep three things in
mind flexibility if
agency and simplicity so flexibility
says you know if you made some some
decisions you know is is that really
going to is that really going to scale
well or is it going to allow you to sort
of change make the decisions changes so
you might want to have fixed task versus
parameterize tasks for example so the
loops that I showed in the previous in
the previous talk each loop that I
paralyzed
had a hard-coded number that said you're
gonna do four iterations that may work
well or it may not work well you know I
can't reuse that code now if I want to
essentially use that kind of data
decomposition and work sharing if I have
a longer loop and I want a longer array
and I want each threat to do more work
so you might want to parameterize more
things in your tasks the efficiency in
that you have to keep in mind that each
of these tasks will eventually sort of
have to talk with other tasks there's
communication costs that have to be
taken into account synchronization so
you want these tasks that actually
amortize the communication costs or
other overheads over the computation and
you want to keep in mind that there's
going to be dependencies between these
tasks and you don't want these
dependencies to get out of hand so you
want to keep things under control and
lastly which is probably as important as
as the other two simplicity and then if
you start decomposing your code into
different chunks in you can't then
understand your code in the end you know
you it doesn't help you from debugging
perspective doesn't help you from a
software engineering perspective or
being able to reuse your code or other
people being able to understand your
code guidelines for data decomposition
are sort of similar and you essentially
have to do tasks and data parallelism to
sort of complete your process and often
your task decomposition dictates your
data partitioning so if you know if
split up a loop into two different
processes I've essentially implied how
data should be distributed between these
two threads and data composition is a
good starting point as opposed to task
parallelism as a good starting point if
you're doing the same computation over
and over
over again over really really large
datasets so you can essentially use that
as your stick to decide whether you do
task decomposition first or data
decomposition first some there's you
know I've just listed to date common
data because the compositions I'll talk
about more of these later on when we
talk about actual performance
optimizations so you want to decompose
arrays for example along rows or columns
you can compose arrays into blocks you
can put them into blocks you have
recursive data structures so a tree you
might partition into left and right
subtrees and the binary tree and the
thing you're trying to get to is to
actually you know start with a problem
and then recursively subdivide it until
you can get to a manageable part you do
the computation and figure out a way to
do the integration I don't think you
know it's like merge sort classic
example tries to capture this really
well so again three seem key concepts to
keep in mind when you're doing data
decomposition flexibility efficiency and
simplicity the first two are really just
meant to sort of suggest that the the
size of the data that you've allocated
actually leads to enough work because
you want to amortize the cost of
communication or synchronization but you
also want the amount of work that's
generated by each data chunk to generate
about the same amount of work so a load
balancing and simplicity just for the
same reason as you know Tassie
composition cannot can get out of hand
data decomposition kid that can get out
of hand you don't want data moving
around throughout and that becomes again
hard to debug or manage or make changes
and interactive Hennessey's pipeline
parallelism this is actually classified
somewhere else in the book actually
lifted it up and and make it trying to
make a case for it and that it's just
good nature I think to expose
producer-consumer relationships in your
code so if I have a function that's
producing data that's going to be used
by another by another function as it
with the spatial decomposition or in
different stages of classic ray tracing
algorithms you want to maintain that
producer
relationship or that assembly line
analogy and you know what are some prime
examples of pipe lines and computer
architecture yeah it's like the
instruction pipeline right in your
superscalar but there might be some
other examples of pipe lines things that
you might have used in say UNIX shell so
cat processor pipe it to another you
know to grep a word and then work out
that so I think it's a natural concept
we use it in many different ways and
it's good to sort of practice that at
the software level as well and there are
some computations in specific domains
like in signal processing and graphics
that have really sort of a you know
where the pipeline model is really
important part of how computation gets
carried out you know you have your
graphics pipeline for example and it's a
little processing we do okay Shea stop
here ten slides okay so so what this is
a brief summary which will lead into a
much larger talk at the next lecture on
how you actually go about re-engineering
your code for parallelism and this could
come into play if you start it with
sequential code and you're paralyzing it
some of you are doing that for your
projects or if you're actually writing
code from scratch and you want to
engineer that for parallelism as well so
I think it's it's important to sort of
understand the problem that you're
working with so you want to survey your
landscape understand what other people
might have done and look for well-known
solutions and common pitfalls and the
patterns that I'm going to talk about in
more detail really provide you with a
list of questions to sort of help you
assess and the existing code that you're
working with all the algorithm that
you're the problem that you're trying to
solve there's some things that you need
to keep in mind that sort of affect your
overall correctness so for example is
your computation numerically stable you
might know if you have floating-point
computation you might not be able to
reorder all the operations because that
might affect your actual precision and
so your overall output might be
different and that may
may not be acceptable so a lot of some
scientific codes for example or things
that have to deal with a lot of
precision might might have to be
cognizant of that fact you want to also
define the scope of what are you trying
to do and will it be good enough so if
you know you want to do back of the hand
back at the envelope calculations to
make sure that things that you're
suggesting about of doing are actually
feasible that they're actually practical
and that will give you the sort of
performance expectations that your that
you've set out you also want to
understand your input range you don't
want you might be able to specialize if
there are some cases for example that
you're allowed to ignore so these are
good things to keep in mind you also
want to define a testing protocol I
think it's important to understand you
know you've you started out with some
piece of code you're going to make some
changes to it how are you going to go
about testing it how you might go about
debugging it and that could be
essentially where you spend a lot of
your time
and then you know having these things in
mind I think the parts that that are
worth looking at our are the parts that
you don't make the most sense where is
your computation spending most of its
time so hot spots and you could and you
can use profiling tools for that and in
fact you'll see some of that for sell in
some of the recitations later in the
course okay so a simple example of a
local or dynamic simulator you what
you're trying to do is you have some
space of molecules which I'm just going
to represent it in 2d and you know let's
say I have water molecules and I have
some you know protein that I'm trying to
sort of understand how it would be
different how do different atoms in that
molecule are moving around so that I can
determine the shape of the protein so
there are forces there bonded forces
between the molecules so I've just shown
example bonded forces among my my
protein and then there non-bonded forces
so how are different atoms sort of
interacting with each other because of
electrostatic forces for example so if
you're trying to understand so what you
try to do is figure out on each atom
what are all the forces that are
affecting it and what is its current
position and then you try to estimate
where it's going
move based on you know Newtonian in the
simplest case in Newtonian F equals MA
type rejection so naive algorithm you
have N squared interactions right you
have to calculate all the forces on one
molecule from all others but you can
sort of understand your problem you know
that you can actually exploit the
properties of forces that essentially
decrease exponentially so you can use a
cut-off distance so if a molecule is way
too far away you can ignore this and you
know for people who do galaxy
calculations you know you need more
geometric forces between consolations or
clusters that are too far apart so in a
sequential code you know some pseudocode
for doing a molecular dynamics simulator
and you have your atoms array your force
array your set of neighbors in
two-dimensional space and you're going
to go through and sort of simulate
different time steps and for each time
step you're going to do for each atom
compute the bonded forces compute you
know who are my neighbors for those
neighbors compute so these are things
that are essentially capsulate distance
compute the forces between them update
the position and so since this is a loop
then that might suggest essentially
where to start looking for concurrency
so you can start with the decomposition
patterns and there'll be more in-depth
details about those next and then I'm
going to give you some intuition and
then you try to figure out whether your
decomposition has to abide by certain
dependencies and what are those
dependencies how do you expose them and
then how can you design and evaluate how
can you evaluate your design screwed up
again it just fixed it okay so this is
the pseudocode again from the previous
slide and you know it since all you have
is a simple loop that essentially says
this is where to look for computation
and since you're essentially doing the
same computation for each atom then that
again gives you to cut the
the type of parallelism that we talked
about before so you can look for
splitting up each iteration and
paralyzing those so that each processor
for example does one atom
or each processor has a collection of
atoms but there are additional tasks so
data level parallelism versus sort of
control parallelism for each atom you
also want to calculate the forces you
want to calculate long-range
interactions find neighbors update
positions and so on and some of these
have shared data some of them do not so
you have to factor that in so
understanding the control dependencies
essentially tells you you know tells you
how you need to lay out your
orchestration so you have your bonded
forces you have your neighbor list that
effect your long-range calculations but
to do this update position I need both
of these tasks that have completed and
in each one of these tasks there's
different data structures that they need
so everybody essentially reads the
location of the atoms so this is good
because in one time step that
essentially says I can I can really
distribute this really well but then
there's a right synchronization problem
because eventually I have to update this
array so I have to be careful about who
goes first there's an accumulation which
means I can potentially do a reduction
on these there are some writes on the
other end but that seems to be a
localized data structure so for
partitioning example neighbors might
have to be you know it's just local to
that different processor so coming up
with this structure and sort of block
level diagram helps you essentially
figure out where where your tasks helps
you figure out what kind of
synchronization mechanisms you need and
it can also help you suggest sort of the
data distribution that you might need to
sort of reduce synchronization costs and
problems and lastly you want to
essentially evaluate your design and you
want to keep in mind what is your target
architecture you know you're trying to
really run on shared memory and
distributed memory and message passing
or you're just doing this for one
architecture so for your projects you
know you're doing this for cell so you
can be very self specific but if you're
doing this in other context the
architecture actually might influence
some of your decisions does data sharing
have enough special properties like the
read-only their data structures that are
read-only are there enough accumulations
that you can exploit by reductions
are there temporal constraints on the on
the data sharing that you can exploit
and can you deal with those efficiently
if you can't then you have a problem and
so you need to resolve that after
designs okay then you move on to the
next design space and so at the next
lecture I'll go through these in a lot
more detail